je pense que je suis un des premiers
informés de l'attentât du world trade
center par la rapidité de sortie du
ministre la façon dont est sorti alain
richard puis hubert védrine indiquent
qu'ils se passe quelque chose de très
grave
[Musique]
je suis seul ce jour là dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée parce que les
médias mainstream globalement ne
s'intéressent pas à ce type de sujet
[Musique]
c'est vrai que quand quand vous partez
sur ce type 2 de commission
vous n'avez pas le sentiment que vous
allez quand même faire un scoop
françois léotard n'intéresse pas grand
monde la macédoine encore moins et
évidemment personne quand on les députés
les ministres rentrer dans la salle on
ne se doute pas un seul instant qu'il
est en train de se jouer
un drame planétaire qui va faire
basculer le monde
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique deux
boeing kamikaze viennent de percuter les
tours du world trade center
il est 9 heures du matin à new york
l'audition est suspendu les ministres
s'éclipse pour rejoindre matignon les
députés découvre ces images stupéfait
d'abord le ministre l'intérieur va
sortir en courant avec son aide de camp
puis le ministre des affaires étrangères
puis tu es députés se ruent vers la
télévision
il ya un silence de cathédrale je suis
en contrechamp parce que j'ai besoin de
voir leurs visages et en même temps j'ai
la curiosité moi même de regarder cette
télévision
donc je me décale légèrement
je me souviens très bien et je vois une
des tours jumelles qui s'effondrent
puisqu'à ce moment là la deuxième n'est
pas encore tombé et donc j'ai la
commission de la défense donc au coeur
de ce sujet qui regardent stupéfait ces
images qui sont hypnotiques qui sont
déroutantes et plus rien n'existe
voulant top tout vingt tables les
américains vous vivre ça comme un
deuxième père larbaud le sommet de
terrorisme aujourd'hui immédiatement le
journaliste pourrait envoyer un tweet et
informer la planète entière dans
l'immédiat témoin je suis en train de
filmer je peux rien faire d'autre que de
filmer c'est une autre histoire c'est du
journalisme à l'ancienne en est né en
2001 la chaîne est plus que jeune elle
est un nourrisson
il faut il faut se légitimer l égard des
députés il faut cjt mais l'égard de
l'institution des fonctionnaires c'est
pas simple mais cette séquence elle
je ne sais pas si elle fait avancer
l'image de cp mais incontestablement
elle donne l'image d'une chaîne qui est
sur le coup qui est là et qui réagit se
passe pas grand chose pour être honnête
en termes de en terme de matière
journalistique qui se passe même rien
mais il se passe cet instant qui dure
une éternité en fait
[Musique]